jean-christophe gallien il et
géopolitologue expert en relations
internationales bonjour merci d'être
avec nous alors on voit qu'il ya une
sincérité qu'on peut qu'on ne peut pas
discuter de la part du président
français
une sincère solidarité avec le liban qui
est un pays proches de la france on le
sait de par son histoire
mais au-delà de cette sincérité est ce
que la france a réellement les moyens de
ses ambitions pour pouvoir soutenir le
peuple libanais aujourd'hui il ya déjà
une posture diplomatique est
particulière c'est celle d'un engagement
personnel du président de la république
il est le premier à venir très vite au
liban est donc finalement d'occuper le
terrain sont bien qu'il ya une volonté
dans un contexte qui est celui du liban
mais élargit son dea ou moins un petit
peu celui de la méditerranée aujourd'hui
de reprendre l'initiative diplomatique
dans un contexte qui est très chahuté
avec beaucoup de concurrents et donc
est-ce qu'il a les moyens il a les
moyens en moins de la parole et les
moyens de la prise d'initiative
après il s'est positionné comme une
interface c'est à dire que c'est à la
fois la france il parle depuis la france
mais il parle aussi finalement depuis le
contexte européen le contexte
international avec en engageant
quasiment des systèmes des organisations
multinationales enfin plus exactement
internationale qui ne qui viendraient en
aide au liban évidemment donc on est
ronde il est à la fois une sorte eu
encore une fois de messager français
mais aussi qui s'est positionné comme un
messager internationale et donc il a les
moyens la prise de parole il a les
moyens encore une fois d'initiative et
après il a les moyens en semble-t-il
économique et financier d'une communauté
internationale qui aurait déjà fait
mouvement vers le liban alors justement
il a il a annoncé quand même une
conférence internationale de soutien et
d'appui au liban pour justement prendre
des mesures d'urgence il a insisté sur
un point précis
une gouvernance claire et transparente
ça c'est un avertissement lancé à la
classe politique au dirigeant libanais
qui sont accusés de corruption par le
peuple libanais soyons clairs le liban
le liban aujourd'hui est dans une
situation pré révolutionnaire
une situation que le semaine ce terrible
ce terrible accident
rappelons le un accident aujourd'hui
encore vient finalement simplement
aggravé mais la population est dans la
rue depuis des mois c'est une situation
pré révolutionnaire à une situation de
quasi-faillite assez inédite c'est à
dire qu'on est dans un contexte où une
élite politique qui rappelons le à la
fois clientéliste et relais pour le gru
tricot on peut qui est là depuis de
longues années qui n'est pas qu'ils
aient quand une fois très diverses et
notamment de manière confessionnelles
extrêmement diverses aides à l'état d'
échec et la population on l'a vu cet
après midi dans les cris les prises de
paroles des malheureux libanais et du
peuple libanais auquel emmanuel macron
faisait face demander finalement le
départ pour pas dire plus sa scène c'est
le gars disons le clairement depuis des
mois et des mois ces libanais sont dans
la rue depuis des mois et des mois est
donc cet accident vient mettre
finalement un éclairage sur quelque
chose qui est à l'oeuvre depuis un long
moment
par contre et c'est là où c'est plus
compliqué c'est aussi le liban un enjeu
géopolitique majeur parce que c'était ça
toujours été le cas mais ça l'est encore
plus parce que ou en face du liban dans
une zone qui est cette méditerranée
orientale il ya aussi un enjeu
aujourd'hui énergétique fort avec
notamment des découvertes de réserves de
gaz et de pétrole qui est si tu les as
betty et qu'il laisse pas présager que
ceux qui détiennent les clés du liban
aujourd'hui voudraient se laisser faire
dont il ya une nécessité effectivement
dans cette initiative de dire on ne vous
aidera pas à ça et airbus qui a été dit
maintenant est ce que ça sera au
restreint c'est plus compliqué à dire on
le vérifiera on ne vous aidera pas si
vous continuer à fonctionner quand un
système clientéliste corrompu mettant
votre état en quasi faillite et plaçant
les gens dans l'obligation d'aller dans
la rue pour deux mondes
et justice du pain de l'argent puisque
disons le clairement aujourd'hui des
libanais ne peuvent retirer pour vivre
au quotidien
tu nous sommes extrêmement modeste et ce
qui leur permet lorsqu'ils ont des
comptes parce que certains comptes ont
été fermés on est dans un contexte qui
quand je dis pré révolutionnaire est
presque un euphémisme est donc encore
une fois est-ce que cette occasion là
peut être saisie par la communauté
internationale qui n'est pas unie loin
de là sur cet enjeu encore une fois
enjeux énergétiques en face des côtes du
liban enjeu stratégique puisque la sir
est quand même pas très loin et il ya
sur le terrain même du liban des acteurs
très opposées l'iran avec le hezbollah
les etats-unis toujours présent la
turquie évidemment très présente
la russie qui est évidemment là aussi on
est dans un contexte très compliqué
emmanuel macron est à la fois en quelque
part
courageux opportunisme et maîtrise
toutes les clés c'est plus compliqué n'y
alors justement elle est la position de
la france ça ne me semble pas changé
depuis la visite du ministre des
affaires étrangères qui accompagne
également et mâcon aujourd'hui mais il
était déjà venu dans la capitale il y a
plus d'une semaine et il avait
conditionné justement l'appui de la
france pour obtenir un accord avec le
fmi à un changement radical à des
réformes profondes
c'est le voeu au cid emmanuel macron
mais on ya une quand même une
problématique c'est ce gouvernement
libanais finalement est-ce qu'il a la
main pour mener ses réformes
on dit qu'il est pris en étau par les
les rivalités politiques notamment le
hezbollah le parti chiite libanais le
hezbollah participe du gouvernement dans
un équilibre
il s'est aujourd'hui constitutionnelle
qui permet aux lits dont de fonctionner
en tout cas de tenter de fonctionner il
est donc partie prenante comme les
autres composantes religieuses de ski et
le liban genre lui puisque ça a été irie
ya une nécessité c'est de faire évoluer
la gouvernance du liban c'est une
nécessité encore une fois demandé pour
le coup aussi par le peuple par le
terrain qu'une partie de la population
celle qui peut s'exprimer librement
qu'ils essaient de le faire
et puis une partie de la communauté
internationale à l'occasion
cet événement mais maintenant ça fait
c'est pas d'aujourd'hui et ses traits
angulaire à cet accident malheureux
encore une fois je je je suis plutôt
pessimiste sur l'idée qu encore une fois
des gouvernements à l'oeuvre aujourd'hui
les gouvernants alors qu'ils le sont
depuis encore une fois plus d'un quart
de siècle puis trente ans ce sont les
mêmes personnes
ce sont les mêmes familles disons le
c'est quasiment les mêmes clans qui
gouvernent aujourd'hui ce pays et qui
lorsqu'ils arrivent par exemple de los
reyes ennemis vous parliez des
négociations à l'oeuvre en ce moment
arrive le plus souvent divisés divisés
sur leur volonté est divisée sur leurs
indicateurs divisés sur leurs
motivations sont ils totalement libre
pour une partie oui pour d'autres ils
ont des donneurs d'ordre qui dépasse les
frontières du liban évidemment donc on
est dans un contexte extrêmement
compliqué et encore une fois j'insiste
sur le sujet c'est que le liban
aujourd'hui c'est partie de cet ensemble
méditerranéen qui est à l'oeuvre avec
une dimension extrêmement forte et
complexe
on a vu ce qui se passe en libye on le
voit dans les relations entre l'union
européenne et la turquie
on le voit avec le beaucoup d'enjeu
notamment lié encore une fois ou
découvertes énergétique dans la zone
notamment de la méditerranée orientale
c'est un ensemble complexe et qui est
traversée par des courants d'actions
qu'ils ne sont pas simplement des
terrains européens nord-africains
égyptiens israéliens et libyens air
situé données dans un contexte qui est
une des nouvelles zones ciblées
d'affrontements ou en tout cas de
conversations géopolitique renouveler et
ça ne garantit pas du tout la réussite
de la mission qui semble-t-il a été
confiée la nuit le matin
merci à vous et à jean claude taffard
eganian je rappelle qu'en 7
géopolitologue expert en relations
internationales merci à vous